however this amended version adds
important new components to strengthen
our Science and Technology agreement and
extends the agreement for an additional
10 years
thank you
[Applause]
well good afternoon everybody
um I am delighted to welcome foreign
minister Park back to Washington
um it's very very good to be with my
colleague and my friend thank you the
Republic of Korea is a vital and
long-standing strategic partner and
I'm particularly grateful to have such a
close friend in Jen to bring this lives
between our countries
even closer
before I talk about the productive
discussions that we had today and the
agreement we just signed Jen if you'll
allow me I'd just like to briefly
address the presence of the Chinese
surveillance balloon in U.S airspace
I spoke this morning with director of
the CCP Central Foreign Affairs office
Wang Yi to convey that in light of
China's unacceptable action I am
postponing my planned travel this
weekend to China
as you know President Biden and
president XI agreed during their
meetings at Bali in November that I
would travel to Beijing to follow up on
their discussions
we've been working across the US
government to prepare for a substantive
set of discussions on issues that matter
to the American people and to people
around the world
and we've been engaging for some time
with our counterparts in Beijing to
prepare for these meetings
yesterday the Department of Defense
announced that we had detected and were
tracking a high altitude surveillance
balloon that remains over the
continental United States
we continue to track and monitor the
balloon closely
we're confident this is a Chinese
surveillance balloon
once we detected the balloon the US
government acted immediately to protect
against the collection of sensitive
information
we communicated with the PRC government
directly through multiple channels about
this issue
members of my team consulted with our
partners and other agencies and in
Congress
we also engaged our close allies and
partners to inform them of the presence
of the surveillance balloon in our
airspace
we concluded that conditions were not
conducive for a constructive visit at
this time
my call today with director Wong Yi I
made clear that the presence of this
surveillance balloon in U.S airspace is
a clear violation of U.S sovereignty and
international law
that it's an irresponsible act and that
the prc's decision to take this action
on the even by planned visit is
detrimental to the substantive
discussions that we were prepared to
have
I told director Wong that the United
States remains committed to diplomatic
engagement with China and that I plan to
visit Beijing when conditions allow
in the meantime the United States will
continue to maintain open lines of
communication with China including to
address this ongoing incident
indeed that's why we need direct and
regular Communications in the first
place and that's why it's critical that
such lines remain open at all times to
help avoid miscalculation and conflict
one final but important note
the world expects the United States and
China to manage our relationship
responsibly
and indeed addressing many of today's
Global challenges challenges that affect
the lives of our people and people
around the world
demands that we find a way to work
together as well
the United States will continue to act
in a way that reflects that
responsibility
we look to our PRC counterparts to do
the same
now the foreign minister and I just
signed an important agreement
that will guide our country's
cooperation on science and technology in
the years ahead
the agreement Builds on one that we
signed in 1992. which helped foster
three decades of consequential
collaboration
our universities conducted joint
research on cancer and climate change
our governments have worked together to
reduce air pollution to promote research
and development on semiconductors which
power modern Technologies cars to
smartphones our businesses have
partnered on life-saving vaccines and
treatments like the collaboration
between the U.S pharmaceutical company
moderna and South Korean biotechnology
company Samsung biologics to manufacture
and a safe and effective covert vaccine
for the region
today's Arrangement today's agreement
will expand the scope of that
cooperation both in areas that we've
longed worked together on like space but
also in emerging Fields like
biotechnology Quantum artificial
intelligence
scientific cooperation is just one of
many areas where our nations are working
together to the benefit of our
populations
another is our shared security an area
where we have enduring ties as our
troops continue to train and conduct
joint exercises side by side
as President Biden has said our alliance
is the linchpin of Peace stability and
prosperity in the region
and is poised to grow stronger still
with the launch of the Republic of
Korea's new indo-pacific strategy this
past December which reflects our own
shared interests and shared approaches
to the Region's most pressing challenges
today we reaffirmed our commitment to
improving our Allied defense against
common threats as well as our commitment
to defending the Republic of Korea using
the full range of U.S capabilities
including nuclear conventional and
missile defense capabilities
earlier this week Secretary of Defense
Austin met with President Yoon as well
as defense minister Lee in Seoul to
boost our deterrence planning including
through even deeper information sharing
on North Korean nuclear threats
we remain committed to the complete
denuclearization of the Korean peninsula
the foreign minister and I also
discussed the importance of maintaining
peace and stability in the Taiwan Strait
we're increasing our trilateral security
cooperation with Japan which puts us on
stronger footing to address shared
security threats including the dprk's
unlawful and Reckless missile launches
we held a series of joint ballistic
missile defense in anti-submarine
Warfare exercises this past fall
we're also deepening our trilateral
collaboration on other security
challenges as well as on helping Pacific
island countries adapt to the growing
impacts of climate change
we're working with other countries to
advance joint priorities like boosting
inclusive economic Prosperity through
the indo-pacific and Beyond including
through the indo-pacific framework for
prosperity and the mineral security
partnership
of course our partnership extends well
beyond the indo-pacific since President
Putin launched his brutal and unprovoked
war in Ukraine our countries have stood
together along with other allies and
partners to impose unprecedented
sanctions and act Force controls
designed to deprive Russia's War Machine
of resources as well as to support the
people of Ukraine as they defend their
country
here too we're working in concert with
Broad coalitions earlier this week NATO
Secretary General stoltenberg traveled
to the Republic of Korea in Japan as
part of his regular engagement with
NATO's asia-pacific Partners
demonstrating the growing Synergy
between our Atlantic and Pacific
alliances
we applaud to the Republic of Korea's
100 million dollars in humanitarian
assistance to Ukraine Aid that has
brought vaccines to Children emergency
medical supplies to families power
generators to communities to replace the
ones Russia has deliberately bombed as
it tries to provide Ukrainian civilians
of heat light and water
this October we'll celebrate the 70th
anniversary of the U.S ROK Alliance
at the treaty signing seven years ago
South Korea's foreign minister Pune
remarked that he was sure and I quote
this written Bond of solidarity would
bring joy and encouragement to all
friends of freedom
Secretary of State Dulles said that the
alliance was and I quote firmly
dedicated to peace
for the past seven decades our alliance
is indeed sustained peace and with the
progress that we've made today I'm
confident that we've taken another step
toward a more secure and prosperous
future
to the benefit of the people of our
countries of the indo-pacific
and of the world with that Jen over to
you
or thank you Tony for your warm remarks
and for welcoming me back to Washington
I would also like to uh thank you our
support team for arranging today's
meeting this year Marx as you said the
historic 70th anniversary of the ROK U.S
Alliance and I'm delighted to kick off
Elon commemorations with my good friend
secretary blinken the ROK U.S Alliance
is one of the most durable and
successful alliances in history
it is special not only due to its
longevity but because it is a vibrant
adaptive partnership that consistently
Rises to the challenges of our times
and president Yun and President Biden
met in Seoul in May last year and
declared that we would develop an
upgraded Global comprehensive strategic
Alliance and we will expand the scope of
the alliance to Encompass not only
political military economic partnership
but also technological and cultural
dimensions
Alliance for the future the 70th
Anniversary slogan aptly encapsulates
this forward-looking spirit and an
alliance in action
today secretary blinken and I had a
productive and comprehensive discussion
on a wide range of topics
first and foremost we discussed ways to
build on the agreements reached by our
two leaders last year to lay out a
blueprint for the next 70 years in
particular we agreed to focus on issues
that benefit our businesses and reassure
and enrich the lives of our citizen in
tangible ways from extended deterrence
to supply chain stability to
cutting-edge Technologies and space
cooperation
our two governments will continue to
enhance strategic communication at all
levels across these critical areas
secretary blinken and I also reaffirmed
our unwavering determination to
denuclearize North Korea this is at the
Forefront and center of our joint
efforts to establish sustainable peace
on the Korean Peninsula peace without
denuclearization is fake peace North
Korea's nuclear and missile programs are
a direct and serious threat to not only
Korea but also International Peace and
security they undermine the very
foundation of the global and
non-proliferation regime
the ROK and the U.S will continue our
watertight coordination to achieve
genuine peace on the Korean Peninsula we
are committed to strengthening extended
deterrence while maintaining a robust
combined defense posture
any provocations by North Korea will be
met with a firm and United response
the secretary and I also agreed to
strengthen efforts to close loopholes
and fully Implement U.N security Council
resolutions as well as to cut off
pyongyang's unlawful revenue streams
country North Korea's illicit cyber
activities must be a priority we agreed
that China has the distinct capability
and the responsibility to influence
pyongyang's behavior
the nuclear denuclearization of North
Korea has long been an area of
cooperation for China as well as ROK and
the United States and it needs to stay
that way we will also embolden Korea U.S
Japan trilateral security cooperation
to address North Korea's escalating
threats we also discussed maintaining
focus on the egregious human rights
situation in North Korea in this vein I
welcome the nomination of Miss Julie
Turner as a new U.S Special Envoy for
North Korean human rights
the secretary and I also discussed ways
to scale up cooperation on economic
security and cutting-edge Technology
just a few moments ago I was pleased to
sign with secretary blinken the protocol
amending and extending
scientific and Technical
cooperation agreement between the ROK
and the U.S
it will strengthen partnership on
critical Technologies by promoting
research and development cooperation as
well as exchange of experts and
knowledge
we agreed that space is the next
Frontier in our expanding partnership
president Jung has stated that Korea
will launch a new Aerospace agency
within this year I was delighted to meet
with the NASA administrator Bill Nelson
yesterday to discuss cooperation on
space that will benefit our civil
commercial and security domains this
year we plan to hold the ROK U.S space
Forum through which we hope to further
strengthen space cooperation
the secretary and I agreed to continue
close coordination to address
disruptions in the global supply chain
we will explore potential for
cooperation under the chips and science
Act
we will also work together to ensure
that the inflation reduction Act is
implemented in ways that address Korea's
Korean companies concerns and benefit
both our businesses and industries
as you may know last year Korea
announced our own indo-pacific strategy
no region is more directly tied to
Global peace and prosperity than the
indo-pacific our respective indo-pacific
strategies squarely Embrace this fact we
will complement and amplify our
engagement in this region in accordance
with the core values of Freedom
democracy human rights and Road of Law
and in partnership with other countries
that share these values
in this regard 2022 was a breakthrough
year for ROK U.S Japan trilateral
cooperation in June our leaders met for
the first time in five years on the
occasion of the NATO Summit
they met again in Phnom Penh and
announced the need to qualitatively
expand trilateral cooperation to deter
economic coercion bolster Economic
Security and Tackle 21st century
challenges together
secretary blinken and I also agreed to
continue efforts towards a swift
conclusion of the war in Ukraine and the
restoration of peace to his incredibly
Brave and resilient people
secretary blinken and I covered a wide
range of issues today this is a
testament to how closely our two
countries have been working hand in
glove at all levels this is truly an
Alliant in action an alliance for the
future that is based on common interest
and a common Vision I look forward to
deepening my partnership and friendship
with Tony in this seminal and historic
year for the ROK us Alliance thank you
thank you we'll now turn to questions
we'll start with Andrea Mitchell of NBC
News
Mr minister
Mr secretary this is the first time
according to the Pentagon that China has
sent a surveillance balloon over the U.S
for such duration and as you have just
said
it's the first time on the eve of a
planned visit by The American Secretary
of State
to China
is canceling your trip or postponing
your trip
enough of a consequence what are the
other consequences
that China should have to take for these
actions
and secondly if I may
what are the opportunity costs of not
meeting
with the Chinese and with the Chinese
president at a time of such tensions
with Taiwan and continuing U.S concerns
over China's support for Vladimir
Putin's invasion of Ukraine
thank you thanks Andrea
um
let me start with this
it's very important to emphasize that
the presence of this surveillance
balloon over the United States
in our skies is a clear violation of our
sovereignty a clear violation of
international law and clearly
unacceptable
and we've made that clear to to China
um
any country that has its Aerospace
violated in this way I think would
respond similarly and I can only imagine
what the reaction would be in China if
they were on the other end
and what this has done is created the
conditions that undermine
the purpose of the trip including
ongoing efforts to build a floor
under the relationship and to address a
broad range of issues that are of
concern
to the American people I believe to the
Chinese people and certainly as well to
people around the world
so we
took the step that uh
I announced earlier today in postponing
the planned visit for this weekend
meanwhile uh we are going to remain
engaged with the PRC as this ongoing
issue
is resolved the first step
is getting the surveillance asset out of
our airspace
and that's what we're focused on
um and I thought it was very important
for wangi the senior foreign policy
official in Beijing to hear this
directly from me it would be premature
for me to weigh in on
any other specifics as this surveillance
balloon remains in our airspace as I
said job one is getting it out of our
airspace
um
we continue to believe that
having open lines of communication
is important indeed this uh incident
only underscores the importance and
that's why we will maintain them and
that's also why when conditions permit
I plan to go to to China but the most
important thing right now in the moment
is to see that the surveillance asset
gets out of our airspace and we'll take
it from there
I don't want to get ahead of anything
other than to say that the first step is
to get the surveillance uh craft out of
our Aerospace
thank you
uh I have two questions firstly to Mr
secretary
North Korea's nuclear address are
increasing every day even openly
especially to South Korea now many
Koreans don't feel safe even be
USS there no better guarantee than the
US versus Korea right but credibility
has declined due to the discussions on
withdrawal during the Trump
administrations and as you know it's not
the first time
this is why there are growing core
sports of Korea to have nuclear weapons
my question is why is the extended
difference currently being discussed by
the U.S and South Korea more reliable
than existing nuclear umbrella clergy
please give me some examples that can
reassure Korean citizens and my next
question is to Mr Park
for the US government U.S government is
not making other people to make a choice
but
while U.S is trying to establish its own
Supply chains Korean companies are
forced to make a change
[Music]
what's Rock government's position to
handle this while we can't really make
one choice or the other
thank you very much
um and I'm happy to start
uh let me be
very clear
our commitment to the defense of the
Republic of Korea as well as to Japan is
Ironclad
and in that light we're also committed
to strengthening our trilateral
cooperation which enhances
both deterrence and the defense
of our countries
we take extended deterrence very
seriously and just in the last year
we've renewed our working group on
extended deterrence
uh We've engaged in multiple exercises
and we have colleagues who at this very
moment are working to strengthen and
deepen even further our collaboration on
extended deterrence
um we are committed to defending their
public create using the full range of
our capabilities nuclear conventional
missile defense capabilities so there
should be no doubt in anyone's mind
starting with Pyongyang of our
commitment to defend our allies our
partners our friends
end to Extended deterrence
regarding your second question
for the International Supply chains uh
there is a very rapid change as you all
know
Korea
is trying its best to to make it
beneficial make the environmental uh
this International beneficial for us and
we're trying very hard for it
SK
[Music]
comprehensively so that we can come up
with the most suitable policy for Korean
situation
Ian Marla limber
thank you uh Mr secretary you've
described the U.S China relationship as
the most consequential one in the world
and yet the Department of Defense also
described this Chinese spy balloon as
not really representing a national
security threat what would you say to
those who might suggest canceling this
very important trip as you've outlined
is in part related to Optics and being
seen to respond to criticism that the
Biden Administration Administration uh
might be soft on China or at least needs
to take a tough response and separately
you've said you'll go when conditions
allow I'm wondering if you might
elaborate on that are we talking a week
or a month and foreign minister Park
um
could you offer a little bit of an
assessment on what you think the U.S
South Korea and Japan can do to cut off
these illicit revenue streams for North
Korea especially including the sale of
ammunition To Russia or cryptocurrency
theft theft and and how do you think
China can be brought into those
discussions thank you
thank you Ian
China's decision to fly a surveillance
balloon over the continental United
States is both unacceptable and
irresponsible
that's what this is about
it's a violation of our sovereignty it's
a violation of international law
and it was
very important that we of course take
the actions we did to um
protect any sensitive information
to protect our people
and
to make clear
to China that again this is an
unacceptable as well as irresponsible
action
it's
even more irresponsible coming on the
eve of a long planned visit that
followed from the meeting between the
two presidents in Bali on the margins of
the the G20
um and
in our judgment it created conditions
that undermined the very purpose of the
trip including ongoing efforts as I said
to build a floor under the relationship
as well as to address a very broad range
of issues that are important
to Americans to Chinese to the entire
world
so that is why
conveyed to uh to Wong Yi the senior
foreign policy official in China this
morning
that I was postponing the travel and
that we will look to see about doing the
trip when conditions allow I'm not going
to put a date or or time on that because
what we're focused right now is on
making sure that this ongoing issue is
actually resolved the first step as I
said
is getting the surveillance asset out of
our space
we got to your question about North
Korea's illicit cyber activities as you
may know after the U.N security Council
adopted stronger sanctions starting in
2016. North Korea's Foreign Exchange
Reserve decreased significantly since
then North Korea has been stepping up
this illegal cyber activities to
circumvent the sanctions regime and
reportedly it has stolen more than 1.2
billion US Dollars by hacking since
2017.
it is more worrisome that Pyongyang uses
such Revenue to develop nuclear and
missile programs in this regard is
illicit cyber activities constitute a
great threat
not only to the global economy and
industries but also to International
Peace and security
so we must consolidate International
efforts to block North Korea's illicit
Revenue stream
and I think Republic of Korea the United
States and Japan should cooperate to
deal with these challenges and by doing
so we will leave Pyongyang with no
option but to return to dialogue and
give up its nuclear development
take a final question from dong hyung
Kim of Beyond half news
Victor Lincoln today you discussed many
ways to strengthen the Korea us Alliance
would a April State visit by President
Yun be considered as one of those majors
Mr Park just last week the Chinese
military aircraft entered the Korea the
Heritage identification Zone and now
there's a Chinese civilians balloon in
the U.S airspace do you consider this
kind of behaviors to be a threat to the
alliance
foreign
President Biden very much values his
relationship and partnership with
President Yoon but I would refer you to
the White House for any uh
any information about any visits
um secretary blinken gave me a very
detailed explanations about the Chinese
balloon incident and I
sufficiently understand
the decision to postpone secretary's
visit to China and I think that China
should
make a Swift and very sincere
explanations about what happened
but at the same time the U.S China
relationship is a very important
relationship in international relations
so at some point in the future I hope
that President Lincoln can have a chance
to visit China and to communicate with
Beijing
thank you Mr secretary thank you Mr
Minister thank you everyone that
concludes the press conference thanks my
friend
thank you
[Music]
when do you think you will be able to go
back